to incorporate our technology in the
day-to-day I think it's it's to learn
the user experience not only on the
interface level but
how the technology can impact the
reality and that that was an extreme
Challenge and
and we we face and we're improving it we
optimizing it and it's an amazing thing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
Isaac Paz welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being here with me
how are you I'm fantastic thank you very
much for having me it's incredible
platform thank you very much uh for for
joining me today I'm really excited to
dive into your world over these 20
minutes and talking about your own
Journey which is
um you know not a trivial one it's not
just a not just the entrep the
traditional entrepreneurial Journey
today you're the founder and CEO of
Safeguard and soon we'll be talking
about how you're leveraging technology
to to to Really you know exemplify the
core of human computer interaction which
is which is really cool and but I'd love
to also touch on a little bit on
um you know your your background and
what led you to to this world and so
Isaac you know we just read to the
audience or the listeners I would say
you know your bio and you know the
different things you've been a part of
can you connect the dots for me a little
bit on what sort of has been guiding you
throughout your own Journey leading up
to now
okay that's uh that quite a journey
my main person is the well-being is
lifespan I introduced to that while I
serving in the military I served in
infantry battalion
and after officer calls I went there
enjoying the
in gulani I served in gulani the
Northern Division of the military
I have decided to go and and manage the
training program of the old division by
thousand soldiers
and I saw the impact that you have on
people's life in your ability to
to
make the division way more competent by
impacting people's life the productivity
and the impact
or significant after I was released I
decided I'm going to focus on health
care because I I thought that's going to
be the main Avenue where I can make a
difference there
overall after having two startups in
California in the healthcare fields I
have decided to come back to Israel I
lived fields in California and then I
started Consulting projects to the
Ministry of Health
to the Department of Occupational
and I saw that Consulting is not
something I want to do
I was exposed by doing that work to a
extreme problem in the construction
industry which a lot of fatally
fatally incidents in the Israeli
construction sector and I was shocked by
by the idea that the
person go to work okay if it goes go
outside to Uncle if they leave the
country
a lot of foreign workers in Israel and
all over the world because they leave
their country come to walk and they
don't come back home you know they they
get killed or get injured and and it's a
catastrophe it's it's a with many many
many injuries and many people dying and
it's if you compare it to a wall Zone
then it's more than a one uh wall Zone
that Israel does in one year they're
doing more than one
a military campaign so have decided to
engage that problem and I discovered
that it's a global problem 2.3 million
people to put similar people die every
year in the workplace
million people people 2.3 million people
die in workplaces around the world every
year that's a lot International labor
organization that's a solid data
what's happening there just so that we
have a perspective what are what are the
leading causes of of
well there is a lot of a lot of
verticals that that leads to that but
specifically Construction
the size it's five starring
in let's say it's a it's ten percent in
terms of
overall the contribution to the economy
but it's five times in injury and
casualties that's why we chose
to focus on that because we said if we
find the solution to the problem in the
construction sector then
then it will evolve and impact other
sector if we Implement technology on
that field
and and the person to protect lives is
it was very strong with me and also with
my team through no matter what to finish
that problem to make sure that you go to
work you come back home that's it and
your life will be protected
so it's it's quite a journey
also I did training in economy but also
in public health
prevention
so I I saw how the world of healthcare
is functioning with kpi with risk
analysis with real time and all kind of
prevention methodologies and I I try to
import that into a field
a dormant feeling like a desert with no
Technologies no data not
because it was quite a challenge
and so you're entering the space You
observe a vacuum You observe the gap
how are you starting to think as an
entrepreneur on what things you can do
to to move the needle there what is the
thought process take me through your own
entrepreneurial Journey there
so
basically to spend two years on the
ground to fill the field
and to test all kind of Technology just
to understand
what are we dealing with so it's not
like we designed the software and the
technology
on on a corporate office it was actually
done in a in a few big groups in Israel
in their construction site so I had my
team of Engineers
every day around the clock to see how
the work is done and nothing cope with
technology in the routine day to day
without disrupting construction project
construction projects Works in what I
Define as a time question
like if we compare dog years to Ivory
which it's one to seven it's also
construction time zone is different
every it's a head dog
a factory that compressed the work of 30
years into four
so everything in terms of time and
engagement is different many languages
many different subcontractor in in
different time Babylon Tower
so it was extremely important that we
invested this fuels to to learn the
field and then
we started to implement different kind
of Technologies and and see what will
work the best I think a b testing was
extremely fundamental to identify who is
the best users that can make the biggest
impact thing it's a general contractor
then and the team and to incorporate our
technology in their day-to-day I think
it's it's to learn the user experience
not only on the interface level but
how the technology can impact the
reality and that that was an extreme
Challenge and
and we we face and we're improving it
we're optimizing it and it's an amazing
thing
so if we fast forward to the main
insights that you've learned through
Safeguard what what are the what are the
really the the key elements today where
technology and AI can leverage to
prevent and predict accidents in
construction
so what I learned is that the
if you have ability to incorporate data
a lot of data in real time
you have the ability to impact the next
decision
so the way we do it is when a user
enters the
the interface still receive a
recommendation or and all the things
that you need to do now but it's based
on everything that the system is
analyzing in real time before and and
when we started we had a regular
application mobile application that with
interface of regular data today we cope
with more advanced data that come from
cameras
that the cameras use a lot of artificial
intelligence in order to to process a
lot of data visual data into
a much more simple data and convert it
to recommendation so the idea is to take
the data and post effect in a way that
the user at the end will get a beep will
get a signal and we'll get a
recommendation an impact these decisions
because the human decision is causing 90
percent of all those problems so and
it's just gonna evolve and we feel that
we need no bigger servers to process
and and a lot of the Mobile Boost
Technologies like drone capabilities in
order to cover as much as possible a lot
of areas to prevent uh any accident from
even occurring
so it's it's amazing times and
challenging time it's uh it's very
interesting
so so Safeguard has been around from
from 2009 right so I'm curious over
these 13 years you know what have been
really the if you had to look back in
you know from an entrepreneurial
perspective and say okay wow these were
the biggest the big Milestones that were
you know that if I look back on these 13
years these are a few key moments that I
really remember they are a part of me
they are part of State safeguards
Journey what would those be
a very good question so if I look
retrospective I think the
the first time is when the national
Social Security fund and decided to
invest which we got basically the public
money into
into a private Venture in order to
to put it together I think that was an
amazing Milestone to get this
recognition and and Believe in Us that
that we can deliver I think they
another serious Milestone is our
basically uh uh
around the a where I I repeated that
Milestone that we fundraised but the
reason I'm looking at the fundraising
Milestones I'm going to also talk about
the crisis Milestone but the reason I'm
talking about fundraising my stories
because a lot of reflection
on people that are experience that kind
of thing business that did big things so
the ability to attack those investors
they that that put their money so often
around they reflected to a bigger group
of people that
that look we are doing something good
here the reflection and and they're
going to go with a long way they are an
exist those
I think in terms of questions
and and you see which staring on the
boat I mean we had the I think two
months we weren't able to pay salaries
like many years back two months and
people staying on the boat
people stay on the boat and and push
them and that was a very
uh transformative moment when you see
who is who is going with you to the
journey and everybody with us until
today
it's a it's phenomenal and now they are
starting to reap the benefit as we move
to a big new development center that's
additional milestone
so it's reflecting to them that as the
company grow and and we do everything
very modest and we go like an old school
company where we do
because we believe in the way so we go
Milestone by Milestone and now we are
international company we do it
relatively slow
and everybody we see that we have slept
all the resources back to them so it
wasn't an empty empty promise and I
think me as the
[Music]
I think it's it's a leadership thing to
be able
to show the way but also to see people
and and reflect to them that we are
achieving those milestones and I think
that's what we're making a company
stronger
to to reflect to the team that together
we can get
a faster and stronger
so going to more towards you know the
leadership style that you have so how
did your leadership
evolve or transform over these 13 years
as a result of this journey
that's that's a challenge actually I'm
facing today but but my leadership
because I'm to be an entrepreneur
mindset and now I need to be more a CEO
and better manager but but and I'm gonna
I want to emphasize because it's really
important to reflect to other
entrepreneurs but in my leadership style
is is to empower more empowering because
they took young people with me and we
needed to somebody that was just
finished it's calling it is today a team
leader so to empower them to invest in a
lot of resources to invest in a lot of
mentorship so empowering people is there
is a muscle that exercises part of my
leadership
and to be a role model like to be fair
to go live
not to take salary when there is tough
times to be a role model it's very very
important to me and I think it's a it's
a it's a it's a good style and I think
to deliver
to deliver to the promise to my workers
to deliver the promise to my customers
what they promised to deliver and to
deliver it to my investors so always to
juggle between me between the
reliability to stand to my world it's
it's a very very important skill set if
you're trying to lead now I'm now
because we grew I need to practice more
along this kind of soft leadership
more technical capabilities of
management
and and now I need to form a skill
Setter the CEO where I need to be have
more routines and more control and
momentary system and process and because
in order to to scale you need to manage
so now I'm learning
uh to be to to also be leader which is
very important to me personally but also
to Be an Effective CEO and that's Now
what is my personal battle I think
corporate these two identities
yeah I mean I can imagine that it's um
it's quite a it's quite an interesting
transition and if you're looking you
know far into the future you know with
safeguarding with your own Journey what
is really the vision that you're setting
here what is what is the vision that
you're living on a daily basis in the
vision that you're sharing with with the
people on on the boat
well we want to have a complete
autonomous safety system that's our
in order to protect working life the
safety system needs to be fully
automated like mobile ID to the car
industry now it's leading the autonomous
car sector so for what it's it's almost
in a way similar to have a complete
automated a safety system and
and we want to be able to be the one
group that
concentrate safety thing the fear the
group that have the sensors
the medical device so we want to be that
group that be the main Arab the main
Global lab of safety Tech
enable us
yeah so what is what what is that what
does that require you in terms of let's
say you know growth or you know the way
that you need to to grow the
organization because there is a
dissonance you know you mentioned before
the one of the you know elements that
you're also very proud of which which it
sounds uh you know right is that you're
doing things you know the right way
you're growing in a healthy way the
company is healthy and you're doing it
systematically and obviously that has
um you know the the way that Tech has
been evolving over the last two decades
sometimes you know other is sometimes
companies have done it the other way
around in order to reach a grand vision
of I guess maybe Blitz scaling or or
getting into you know everywhere so how
do you balance between those two ideas
as a part of a greater Vision to be
deployed at scale
you think you have a good question I
think that they it's the strategy that
counts and I'm I'm looking on on two
time
two time frame I have a strategy that
it's a 30 to 50 years time frame which
is more long-term strategy I'm
I'm very connected to the fact that
Islamic is where I need to have massive
Enterprises and not just sell them but
you have a 30 to 50 years vision and
also I have an incremental vision of
five years at the time of multiplier
evaluation for investor so I need the
fuel so in order to put the fuel in the
car
I need to assure that the investor can
make seven to ten times on his money in
a five-year period and then a 30 50th
strategy is again to consolidate the
safety Tech Market will be in the future
will be acquisition when the future
would be collaboration there will be a
lot of
strategies that every
place in the world that will see here
our brand will know that
we know that it's a sure protection that
it assure safety
so it's a long term but not all the time
you can sell investors the 50th Visa but
you definitely can sell them the
the valuation but in order to be big
company you need to understand deep that
you need to move slower and that's it's
really important because you can maybe
be big in a certain point of time when
you move fasting but then you are very
volatile
to really be big you need to move a bit
slower to be more strategy sometimes to
be observant in a market where other
competitors fight and know where to
where to strike its it's it's more old
school it's more it's full with
technology
but but we I have in terms of drug
records for 2017 when it we started the
fundraising and until today
which is five years
we grow several times seven times
so and that's with dilution and
everything so I I think I think overall
because it's important to issue there is
a need for it it's heavily regulated
so it's with the good fundamental
strategy and and patience we will be
able to achieve what we want to achieve
incredible it's like thank you so much
for the time and for the insights uh
best of luck with the your journey very
rare to hear about entrepreneurs talking
about 30 or 50 year visions and I think
it obviously speaks volumes to um to
your own journey and what led you to
start safeguarding where you're at today
so thank you very much I'll continue
cheering from the side and best of luck
thank you very much for the opportunity
thank you